you also turned me on to things like
solitude what solitude oh the game show
solitaire solitaire is what it is all
sorry my bad
have you guys seen this No one of the
best game shows reality should the
12-year old does it yeah yeah yeah
that's exactly what it is
everybody's and the crazy thing about
everybody's eight contestants are in
their own solitary confinement going
crazy the whole thing is they have to
challenge themselves you know the vowel
or whoever is like hi you must eat all
these bugs until all of the other ones
quit something like and you have to push
yourself as far as you can right there's
like eight or nine contestants in these
rooms Fox reality reality like the end
of a pole right and you have to just you
know me hang onto the pole whereas foot
drops onto the floor is eliminated so
then like twelve hours of you have like
three white dudes left you make Klingon
yeah but they can't see each other you
don't know oh well they're doing so it's
you gotta master your own will then Wow
and when you when you fall you got a
pope that you were the last so some fool
could be there for 12 hours just hanging
by himself but you know what the the
fascinating thing about that show I know
you must have loved is it seemed to
prove that Asian people had a pain
tolerance and endurance and push
themselves Asian guys or girls [ __ ]
went though crazy and that's you know
what that's called my friend evolution
you really amazing I know I'm French
whatever whatever it is something
right now okay you all right I'm good
yeah yeah it's you know here on my
machine you're saying that Asian people
are different
higher form of humanity and I didn't say
that they say higher well our orphan
that's different
more more progressed not even progressed
yeah you think a little smarter a little
air Lola you know men and more evolved
so that yeah I didn't say better I
didn't say any of those higher I didn't
say higher how no China I love it such
an ancient civilization yes so you think
that how is that like in the final stage
of evolution it's not the final we're
still evolving my friend yes built for
torture excuse me well that's Lippitt
you can say you're evolved are also just
built for torture it's true I mean how
come like every Korean movies like
somebody's getting tortured all right
it's always revenge especially Korean
Japanese it's the weird it's torture
it's worth trying
yeah yeah that's a shame and torture
shame and torture remember audition
chicken why anybody jerk off to that I
did I did find it strangely her sexy
yeah she was definite so that's crazy
it's crazy yeah because she just looked
so just porcelain and innocent working
work girl crawls out of a woman's vagina
I think goes you it was or something
like that same guys
Mika Takashi yeah yeah same dude no I
haven't seen that one
wailing yet I saw the wailing loved it
yeah it was very cool I hold the cat the
cat what's a cat you want Allegra
something um yeah get her in here
yeah get in Allegra um I'm so sorry
about the cats
no problem oh you know I have to but
yeah that one was that one was cool that
was classic Korean batshit crazy cool oh
yeah we got a we got a DEFCON 5 I'm in
I'm in yeah yeah yeah
is that better do some dr. pepper throw
it's not closing up no my I'm good I
mean it's just gonna be it's gonna be uh
you're not gonna you're not gonna open
it for old [ __ ] it's one of those
[ __ ] yeah you got it
all right okay imagine just instantly
works right now
yes have some tissues as well yeah
Jordan yeah this [ __ ] director no is
not even [ __ ] bro
this is how I know it works reality is
is the real it's part of the thing now
ie but though the whaling was it was
weird
yeah what was weird and I had to wit
agree watch it and Google everything cuz
I was still very confused about the
ending because it could be interpreted
several different ways yeah and I Google
to to and from what I can tell it's like
no one really knows
[Music]